[Music]
thank you all for taking some time
out of your day we're going to start by
looking at
in our markdown document and how we can
use r and python together inside of that
document
with some special new magic that's
available in the latest versions of our
studio
we'll also talk about how once we've
finished that document it can be
published and shared in a reproducible
way so that others can view it
and perhaps you might introduce some
lightweight automation
we'll look briefly at how a similar
outcome can be achieved with jupiter
notebooks
using shared infrastructure and then
we'll talk about how
the model we're creating in this
document
can actually be put in into place so
that decisions can be made based on that
model
and we'll look at how you can maybe do
that within interactive app
or through something like a restful api
and then finally we'll talk about how
those apis and applications can also be
developed
using some of the new options inside of
the rstudio toolset
so we'll go ahead and jump in
and to set a little bit of context i am
using
rstudio on a server and so that means
i'm going to access rstudio through a
web browser
and there's a couple of really nice
benefits to doing this the first is that
i have more resources available to me
than i would
on my laptop and specifically if i go in
to start a new session
you'll see we're taking advantage of a
tool called kubernetes
that allows me to kind of on demand
specify
what resources i want for this work
another benefit of using a server
is that it means everyone on my team lou
and myself
are speaking from a common playbook and
in this case we're explicitly defining
our environment
through a docker image where our session
is going to run but even if you're not
using kubernetes or docker
by having your work on a server everyone
has a common home
which helps make collaboration a lot
easier and then finally because we're on
a server
we're a lot closer to our data which
means our work can scale
in an easier fashion now in a moment
i'll be jumping into the rstudio ide
but while i'm here i just want to point
out that one of the things we've done in
the last year for multilingual teams
is added the ability for other editing
tools
to be accessed from this same interface
so it's almost like a workbench
where you can pick up the right tool
from that workbench regardless of
what language your current project
demands
and that means for multilingual data
science teams everyone has
all those benefits i just described of a
common playbook regardless of what
editor they're using
and for it it's really nice to have this
common front door
where these different environments are
going to be accessed
so we'll go ahead and jump into our
studio
and at this point i want to point out
that everything you're going to see
inside of the rstudio ide even though
i'm using rstudio server it's going to
be available
in any flavor of the rstpuide so whether
using the open source desktop or rstudio
server open source or the professional
product like i am
you'll have access to the
interoperability that we're about to go
through
so to set the stage just a little bit
more i'm doing my work here
inside of an r markdown document if you
haven't seen our markdown before
it's basically a format where i can
combine prose
so what i'm thinking along with my code
and then the output of my code but
what's new in the latest version of our
studio
is something that we're calling the
visual editor and what that means is
that even though i'm editing in our
markdown document
on the fly i'm getting a live rendering
of what this document looks like
so that means i can do things a little
bit easier than i used to
so for example if i needed to put in a
table i could insert a table really
quickly
i can add mark down to that table and
it'll be rendered on demand
i can even do things like insert
citations or emojis
and so i can use all these different
tools
inside of the visual editor and whatever
i'm doing is going to show up
as kind of a real time preview and the
reason why i think this is so important
is that regardless of what language
you're
working from ultimately a data
scientist's
key job is to communicate and so being
able to write effectively
in a tool that supports really rich
technical communication
is vital for any type of data scientist
and i've found that this visual editor
makes things that used to be challenging
for that type of technical communication
really easy one of my favorites is i can
go in here
and actually insert an image i don't
have to worry about figuring out where
that image lives on disk
and i can even resize it interactively
so we hope that regardless of what
language this visual editor
is going to give you a head start as
you're
writing down what you're thinking and
documenting your process
and it really combines kind of the best
worlds of the jupiter notebook
in the rstudio ide and our markdown and
if you haven't seen this before
inside the latest version of our studio
all you need to do is click this button
in the upper right hand corner and what
that button does
is flip us back and forth between the
plain text
source code that's still available here
perfect for version control
and that pre-rendered view of the
document
all right so that's where we're doing
our work is inside of this visual editor
what are we going to do well we have
kind of a made-up data science exercise
and so like most data science exercises
we're going to start by pulling in some
data
and this data is coming from a database
and again something that we're excited
about regardless of what language you
use
is the ability within our studio to
seamlessly manage
connections to databases and so here i
have a connection to a database called
content
there's a number of different tables
inside of it and without switching to a
different
sql editor i can really easily preview
the schema
of this database table and even preview
some of the records if i want
so i have this database and
i'm starting out by writing some r code
that's going to operate within the
database
to do some basic transforms and so if
you haven't seen this before
using dplyr you can write our code
and then that r code actually gets
executed as sql
so that's what's going on here so we're
creating some
data that we're then going to do an
analysis on
so let's take a quick look at that data
essentially we have spatial temporal
data
and so we're looking at bike share data
from the dc area
and so those bike shares if you've ever
been walking around the city
and you want to rent a bike you can
usually find a station with bikes lined
up
and then you pay some money to be able
to ride the bike around and so the data
that we have
is how many bikes were available at any
given
station at any point in time so we have
kind of this time series
of bikes that are available then we also
have kind of a spatial component
of where those bikes were located so
it's a pretty cool data set
and what we want to try to do is
forecast
into the future for a given station how
many bikes might be available
and say i have to commute home at 5 00
pm
is there going to be a bike there that i
can take and so we'll get started by
doing that
in r and the first thing that we're
going to do is create
a test and training data set and because
we're working with time series data
it's really important that we don't
accidentally use the future
to predict the past and so in our we've
created
a test and training data set where the
training data set
sequentially occurs before the test data
set
and now that we have these two things we
can go ahead and build our model
and i'm using a new r package or an
ecosystem of our packages called tidy
models
there's a lot of great resources online
if you want to dive into modeling and r
but essentially what this set of
packages is allowing us to do
is pre-process our data and so we have
here kind of latitude and longitude
that's the spatial element
we have the date and time that's the
temporal element
but we've used some pre-processing
tricks to create a factor for the day of
week
and also add some information about
whether a given day was a holiday
so you have a nice rich data set to do
modeling on and then you know the first
thing that we might do
is create a model uh in r
and so to do that again within this tidy
model's ecosystem
i'm essentially creating a workflow
that's going to
take our model pre-processing along with
this
gradient boosted engine and fit a simple
regression model
so we can go ahead and do that and if we
look at the results here
we have a predicted number of bikes
along with the actual number of bikes
kind of what we'd expect
and we can evaluate how our prediction
did so one thing
that we can do for that quick evaluation
is
plot the prediction versus the reality
and if our model was really good all of
our data points would fall
along this y equals x line where
predictions match reality
you can see we have quite a bit of
variance from that line
we could look at like the r squared
value of our model
and see that oh it's not very good
um that's why i'm paid to give webinars
and not fit models
but this hopefully gives you a sense of
kind of what your your workflow might
start to look like on r
uh we can even because this is a tree
based model
look at feature importance and so you
can see that our model is emphasizing
the location
of our bike share station uh and not
putting as much weight on some of those
factors that we created
so we have this you know iffy model in r
what do we want to do next well we could
try a lot of different things to improve
our model
one thing we might want to do is try
something from the python ecosystem and
so that's where
kind of the heart of this webinar begins
which is how are we going to
interoperate python and r inside of this
same context
well the first thing that we'll do is
create a python code chunk
and inside of that python code chunk one
of the things that we're going to want
to do right
off the bat is import some packages so
i'll go ahead
and add the code to bring in these
packages
and we can do a quick sanity check here
to run the code chunk
and it appears that we have these
packages loaded inside of python
now i can already see in the chat that
many of you are asking you know how is
python managed where are these packages
coming from
those are really great questions so the
latest version of our studio
you can use a project or global option
to specify what python interpreter
should be used
in the context where you're mixing are
in python together
and so for this project i've created a
virtual environment
and i've selected and told rstudio to
use that virtual environment
you can see that rstudio is actually
aware
of kind of the multitude of python
installs that are available on this
server and that's one of those benefits
again of working on a server
is that if lou and i were collaborating
together we'd have this common
understanding of what python
installations are available
so that's where the python engine is
coming from
the python packages themselves are
coming from a tool called rstudio
package manager
so in our case our server is not online
you know we have some sensitive data
that lives in our environment so we're
not able to go reach out to the internet
so instead package manager acts as this
intermediary
where we can install python packages
from
a specifically governed mirror
of pipi and so that's what you're
looking at here
i can search for packages i can see
information about those packages how to
install them what they depend on
but something that's really special
about this mirror is that it has
a safety net that allows me to time
travel as well
and so if i ever got into a situation
where my python environment wasn't
working
i could go backwards or forwards in time
to reinstall packages from a specific
point in the past
so that's where these packages are
coming from let's go ahead and start
writing some code
and this is where i think get things get
really magical
because within this python code chunk
inside of my our markdown document i
actually have
access to everything that i've done up
until this point
in r and you can actually see the ide
here is helping me auto complete
some of the objects that are or
attributes of this special r
object that are available and so what
does that mean
well i'm going to cheat a little bit and
grab some code that i've
written ahead of time
we'll just put this inside of our code
chunk
and then i can walk you through it so
the first thing i'm doing
because we're going to fit this model in
python is load
some training and test data but you can
see that i'm not
starting from scratch i'm using this
magic r object
to actually pull in the
training and test data that i already
created
and then i can use that as a jumping off
point for fitting my model
and so we're going to do a little bit of
pre-processing with pandas
and then we're going to use some
functions from scikit-learn
to fit another type of model and one of
the things that's really
interesting and why we might jump into
python here
is that scikit-learn has native support
for time series cross-validation
so remember i said we can't use the
future to predict the past well psychic
learn knows how to handle that
even in the case where you're doing a
whole bunch of cross-validation fitting
and so that's what we're doing here to
fit an svr model
i can go ahead and run this python code
chunk
and we can take a look at our results
all right so train results dot mean
that's the mean
of our cross validation r squared value
and you can see
it's really bad okay so i'm not
a great python model fitter but
hopefully you get the idea
that we can really seamlessly reuse
things back and forth
and you might have noticed a couple of
other things that the ide is doing to
help me with this python development
so one of the things that i briefly
mentioned is that autocomplete
and so say we wanted to use a different
model from scikit-learn you can see the
ide
is providing me with all the different
options that are available
all the attributes and methods of these
objects and the help for those methods
that
arguments that they take are also all
going to be available in the ide
with the rich auto completion that you'd
expect
the other thing that i'll point out is
if we look at our environment pane
when we switch to the python context we
actually got a python environment
explorer as well and so these objects
that i'm creating
inside of python i can actually see them
and explore them inside of the ide
and i could even preview them as well
so this becomes a really rich way to
interactively do your work
and debug problems and you can see that
even things
like the filter capability inside the
ide
as well as sort work for these python
objects
i can also switch at any time back and
forth between r and python
because the two ecosystems are
coexisting together inside of this
notebook
speaking of which there's one last trick
that i want to show you
so i've fit this python model and i have
some python predictions
what if i then wanted to go and do some
further analysis
well you saw how i can reuse r objects
in the python context but i can do the
same thing
inside of r so inside of r there's this
magic object object called py
that gives me access to everything that
i've created so far
in the python space and so i can go
ahead
and use that object to do something
like this if i grab some code
for my cheat sheet place it in this
chunk
i'm essentially taking
the python model predictions and
plotting them with ggplot2
and you can see a little bit here why
our modelfit is so bad
it's because we're not capturing nearly
any of the variants
that is going on inside of our data all
right
so we've fit this model that combines r
and python together inside of a notebook
what do we do now well at our studio
we're big believers
that you should share your data science
work early and often
this is the best way for people with
domain knowledge or stakeholders
to validate that you're on the right
path
and so one way to do that that's really
powerful
is through publishing and within our
studio we can publish
you see this blue icon here and we can
publish to a number of places but within
a team enterprise setting our
recommendation is to publish to rstudio
connect
and so i'll go ahead and do that you can
see the id identifies my dependencies
and what happens when i click publish is
that a reproducible unit
is created here that contains not only
my code
but also things like the version of r
the version of python
the different packages that i need to
reliably reproduce this document
and so i'll go and show you the end
result here on rcdo connect
which is that same rendered notebook so
we have kind of all the information
that i have been working up to this
point
but in the context where i can easily
share it with others
so i can specify who should be able to
see this
and because it's that reproducible unit
at any point i can reliably refresh this
document to regenerate the results
or i could do something like set up a
schedule so my data might change over
time
and i might want this notebook to
re-render on a regular basis
and i can set all that up because the
dependencies are intertwined
in a reproducible unit with this
document
now you might be thinking that's great
if you're our studio
user which probably most of you are but
what about my colleagues on the python
side
well the same option is available for
sharing your work early and often
if you're coming from python and so i
want to quickly show you what that looks
like
uh in the rcu ide we clicked that blue
publish button
and inside of jupyter notebooks you can
click that blue publish button as well
but i want to show you a slightly
different way that you can quickly and
easily share your content
and that's to import content from a
system like git
so what i have here is a git repository
that get repository contains all of the
example code
we've been talking about today and it's
a public repository so you can go ahead
and play around with this as well if
you'd like
what i'm going to do is take this git
repository
and tell our studio connect to import
that content
and so i have different branches that i
can choose between
and then this repository has a number of
different directories
i'll go ahead and import the jupyter
notebook i'll give it a title here
and what happens when we import this
content is the same thing that we saw in
interactive publishing
the environment this content depends
upon is recreated
so i have a reproducible unit of work
around
my notebook now if i go and open up that
notebook
i can see the results so i can share
this
even with a non-technical user who might
be intimidated by the standard jupyter
notebook interface
here they just have a really clean html
document that they can read
and a data scientist can specify who
should be able to see this content
but also do the same things i was
talking about for scheduling or
re-rendering the content on demand
so we have our notebooks we've shared
them early and often that's great
we've gotten this domain feedback and
maybe we iterate a couple of times and
really improve that model
what do we do then how do we ensure that
the model
is actually being used to generate
decisions
that's kind of the key task of a data
science team
well there's two ways that we think
about this at our studio
one is to influence how decision makers
are making decisions through your model
and a great way to do that is through
interactive applications
so many of you might be familiar with
tools like shiny which allow you to do
that
in r but we've worked hard in the last
year
to ensure that multilingual teams have
that same capability
so what you're looking at here is a dash
application
which is a interactive application
written in python
and what this application is going to
allow us to do
is help stakeholders understand our
model
so they can come in here and click
through different stations
and see the forecast and the location of
the station
so it's a pretty simple app but
hopefully it kind of gets your wheels
turning
that even if you're a python data
scientist or you work with python data
scientists
they have the same ability to impact
decisions by creating interactive
content
and we see examples of that with dash
with streamlit with bokeh
with a wide variety of interactive
python frameworks
that are supported through the rstudio
stack
so that's how you might go about
influencing a person
with your model but what if you need to
use your model to make
a whole bunch of automated decisions or
if you need to influence
not a person but a service uh
one way that's common to solve that
problem is by creating an
api and again there's options for doing
this
in r and python so on the r side we have
tools like plumber
on the python side we have tools like
flask
and both of these can be shared just as
easily
through rcu connect and so i'll just
quickly show you what that
api might entail again we have all of
the same controls
and so we can look at the the logs of
this plumber api
we could do things like scale if we know
we're going to have
thousands of requests this api at the
same time we can specify how we want the
system to handle those requests
but at the end of the day the idea is
pretty simple it's that
anyone can come in and place a
parameter of your model in this case
we're specifying the station that we
want to make a prediction for
and the time horizon that we want to
make a prediction for
and then those inputs are passed to our
model
and the results are returned so here we
have the results of our forecast
but as you can see that passing of
inputs and outputs
is done in a way that machines can
understand so here we have the output in
json
and just above that we have the request
that are kind of
interactive exploration of this api
would
generate so other systems or services or
software engineers
can take advantage of your model at
scale
all right so we've covered quite a bit
of ground we've talked about how to make
these models through notebooks
we've talked about the different ways
that you can
enhance those models and put them into
production i didn't actually show you
the code
for either that dash application or this
api
so that's the last thing that i wanted
to do is talk a little bit about how you
can get started
writing this type of code and so if i go
back to the rstudio id
if you're an r user my recommendation is
to just click
new file and you'll see a bunch of
options two of which are shiny web
applications
and plumber apis so those are going to
get you started
with creating either web apps or apis
if you're a python user inside of the
rco stack
we looked at jupiter notebooks but if
you want to do this type of
coding for apis or applications you're
probably going to need a little bit more
robust
editor and you can use either jupyterlab
or vs code for that purpose
if i open up visual studio code
the kind of last thing i want to show
you here is just how easy that
deployment of an api or an application
is
so inside of vs code again i'm
working off of that shared common python
environment
so it's easy for me to collaborate and
automatically get the right python
environment as all my colleagues
i have my code here for a dash
application
and then all i need to do to deploy is
use
a utility that we've created called rs
connect so this is just a python package
that you can install
really wherever you're you're writing
python code and it has commands to help
you
then take that python code and wrap it
up in that
reproducible context so for example i'll
do rs connect
deploy dash to a server called dev
and it's going to run through and
identify all the dependencies of this
application
and then give me the link to the
deployed app
and if we follow that link you'll see
the exact same
bike share application we were looking
at before
so to recap we covered quite a bit of
ground we created that document using r
and python and some really cool r studio
magic
that document was shared in a
reproducible way we talked about how
jupyter notebook users can do the same
type of early and often sharing
and then how we can use that model to
impact decisions either through apps or
apis
and finally how you might go about
writing those things using some of the
new features in the rstudio workbench
with that i will hand things over to lou
who's going to
kind of bring us home and then we'll
have the q a
thank you sean that was great so um
so while sean was talking i was taking a
look a lot of the
questions coming in via slido um there
are a number of questions there that
have been upvoted
some of which that um you know sean
covered a lot of that material
uh in his demo after those questions
came in but we'll get to as many of
those as we can
um so sean showed off a number of
different things
here for the data scientist he showed
how
you can use these two languages closely
together
without a lot of overhead so that data
scientists can use each language for
their own strengths
also illustrated some of the different
ides that can be used
allowing data scientists to use their
preferred id ide again
making that easy and we now support in
addition to the id
the rstudio ide of course jupiter and vs
code visual editing of our markdown is a
great advance
again making the user experience the
developer experience for data scientists
much easier
and to answer one of the questions in
the q a that visual markdown is
available in the open source version of
the rstudio ide
so a number of different ways that data
scientists can use r and python to
deliver these wow results to the rest of
the organization
for the devops and i.t teams using these
centralized
environments makes it easy to support
these common tools for both r and python
and opera operationalize both languages
without doubling the work
and by making both of these languages
easy to use together it helps
data science leaders really optimize
their team for the people
not for an arbitrary choice for single
language
to better enable collaboration within
the team and within their stakeholders
and really able to access these wider
talent pools to hire new data scientists
into their team
and finally for the business
stakeholders in the organization
ultimately they don't care about what
the underlying language is
they just want to have reproducible
accurate
understandable data science insights
that they can use to help
make better decisions so by sharing this
data science work through platforms like
connect
they can access this up-to-date
interactive analyses and dashboards
or get the information directly in their
email so they can get the answers they
need
in order to make better decisions
all these capabilities are supported by
the rstudio team
set of products which together combine
to provide a single home for r and
python data science teams
again our studio server pro is the
centralized environment
allowing data scientists to use r or
python to analyze data and create these
data products
rstudio connect is a platform to publish
results to make them available to
business users
and other stakeholders using our
python-based data science products
and our studio package manager to manage
open source
packages for both r and python one of
the questions that i saw
in the q a was a question of you know
expressing
pain around how difficult it is to
manage packages in the python ecosystem
and we've recently added support for
managing packages from pipi
to our studio package manager to help
address that exact
pain point and i'll ask sean to comment
on that in the q a section
our studio is of course used by millions
of people uh
every week using our open source
software things like the ide
and the tidy verse and shiny critical
open source applications that we create
as part of our open source mission
we're also used by thousands of active
commercial software customers including
over half of the fortune 100
and many well-known brands such as the
ones we see here
we also have been really gratified to
hear from
our customers via trustradius.com so if
you
are an rstudio user we encourage you to
go to trustradius
check out the r studio profile read some
of the reviews that people have left
there
and add your own review because we read
every single one of these
we try and respond and certainly these
are one of the one of the ways that we
hear from our users we've gotten
great feedback from our customers on
combining r and python
in a single platform and how it helps
them collaborate among their team
and to essentially allow these teams to
as the
second reviewer says make use of their
preferred language for data analysis
so that they can create and publish
products via our studio connect using
both r and python
to share with their internal clients and
stakeholders as the third reviewer
shows here
now we've talked a lot along the way
about our pro products
but i want to emphasize that our core
mission is to engage
and support the r and python community
and we do that in a number of different
ways
the most important of course is creating
the open source software
that our users use every week
but there are a number of different ways
we do it we support the our
r studio community site allowing our
users and python users to gather and ask
each other
questions and get answers to those
questions that's a great resource
we do our annual conference um this year
it was a virtual conference
under current circumstances but that was
just a couple weeks ago
and we were very gratified by the
engagement there
check out our blog and there's a link
there
to all the globals oh sorry all the
videos from our studio global
many different speakers from all around
the world those are all free to watch
we had a tremendous amount of positive
feedback both directly on social media
on that conference so encourage you to
check out those videos
our education team is focused to
help support the education of our we do
a lot of
train the trainer capabilities providing
training materials etc
so if you're interested in being a
certified r studio r
trainer check out our education page
we're also supporters of the our
consortium um
a multi-vendor group to support and
advance the
infrastructure around the r language as
well as a platinum
sponsor of num focus which provides a
tremendous support for the python
ecosystem
among other projects and then finally
ursa labs
we've been a supporter of ursa labs from
the
beginning
and ursa labs is devoted to developing
cross-language capabilities
such as using the apache aero project to
provide
access both within r and python to those
capabilities
and it's important to emphasize how our
open source and pro
products tie together of course it's our
core mission as i said
to contribute open source software to
the community
and we spend over half of our
engineering resources creating this free
and open source software
as the data science community adopts
open source software this
drives adoption within larger
enterprises
and commercial customers these
commercial customers in turn
buy our pro products that are focused on
helping scale out and operationalize
open source data science
and by buying our pro products that
provides our studio the funds so that we
can sustain our ongoing
open source work we call this idea the
virtuous cycle
this idea that we're supporting our
mission um to deliver free and open
source software to the community
by selling the pro software to the
enterprise companies that need
those features
so if you'd like some more information
we have a number of different resources
again these slides
and the recording will be sent out
within a few days after the webinar
rstudio.com python is your one central
portal portal to
get to a lot of this information we also
did a blog post
uh recently on recapping all the python
related features we added in both our
open source
and pro products over the last year so i
encourage you to take a look at this
if you'd like to set up a time to talk
to us one on one you can use this url
here
rrstd.io r underscore and underscore
python
to learn more set up a meeting get some
answers the webinar recording will be
available on our resources site
if you'd like some more technical
information and a number of the
questions in the q a
were looking for more technical details
check out some of these links
the reticulate package website
as well as providing some examples and a
webinar on that topic
we also on our solution.rtstudio.com
site we've got a number of
articles providing deeper information on
how to integrate python
in our studio server pro and our studio
connect
again those are all accessible through
the top level rstudio.com
python portal and for our community site
is a great place
to ask questions about r and python open
source and pro
now going through the q a
the most popular question was how to
you know as an r user how can i learn
python what would you recommend
to uh experienced our users i did a
quick poll to our education team
um and these couple of books uh floated
to the top
are you know python for data analysis or
python data
science both of these books were
recommended by our education team
as being more data first as opposed to
programming first
i will try and get a few more
recommendations to add to this slide
before we share it with the participants
and i would add to that loop as part of
this webinar
afterwards we'll be sharing information
uh
on the rcu community page that uh our
stud
dot io slash rpi qa link
the link that is currently bringing you
to slido with all the questions
will be redirected to that community
thread we'd actually love
for all of you to give input to answer
that question as well
uh because there's a lot of diversity in
how people learn
we we know these communities are coming
from very different
you know people and lots of diverse you
know backgrounds
and so if you have something that's
worked really well i would recommend
replying to that community thread we'd
love to kind of open source the answer
to that question beyond us at our studio
that's a great point sean thank you very
much
so with that sean or is there any uh
particular questions that uh you'd like
to kick off with
yeah absolutely i think you know one of
the most common questions
uh was you know what what parts of that
demo are available
you know on the open source side what
parts are part of the professional
products
and so apologies if i didn't do quite
enough sign posting there to delineate
uh essentially everything that you saw
on sort of the rstudio ide
so that visual editor of our markdown
documents
the ability to combine r and python
inside of our markdown document
selecting what python interpreter to use
the python
objects in the environment pane the
python
repel even those are all going to be
in that open source desktop id
regardless of what version you use
and in fact i would encourage folks to
look at the reticulate website
that talks a bit more about some of the
options that i didn't
dig into for combining r and python
in that open source way i mean one of
the questions
asked if i just have a python script can
i use that in our studio
and the answer is absolutely that's
something that i didn't show but it is
available in the open source ide so i'd
encourage folks to
to go there the things that were
specific to our professional products
uh would be the selection of different
editors
from that common workbench as well as
the deployment of work to rcu connect
um i i would encourage folks especially
there was some
folks who were saying i work at a
research institution or
i'm teaching at a university and i would
benefit from some of those professional
capabilities
i would encourage you to reach out a lot
of the professional products we give
away for
free if you're teaching and are pretty
discounted for research as well
so hopefully that helps answer that kind
of common question about
what can i do on my own today everything
inside of our studio ide
what would be part of the professional
products that would be
anything you saw in terms of sharing or
the different
editors within the rstudio workbench
thanks sean so one of the other really
popular questions and i i alluded to it
earlier is this idea of the challenges
of package management in python
um and this is an area i'm particularly
excited about
because of the recent edition of pi pi
support in our studio package manager
you know initially in beta would you
like to comment on that at all
yeah absolutely so i would tend to agree
it is a bit of a mess that certainly is
kind of my experience
right now the rstudio ide sits on top
of kind of the many python management
tools that are available
and so if you already have a tool of
choice
you saw in my demo i was using a virtual
environment
if you're using something like conda or
poetry or pyenv
the r studio id will sit on top of all
of those options
and in fact uh the kind of key engine
behind all of this
is an open source package called
reticulate
and within that package you can see the
different functions
that help the ide and r identify what
python environment to use
that's also something that you'll see in
the options menu that i mentioned
where if you go inside of our studio id
and click tools
options uh basically any of those python
environments whether they're from conda
or
virtual and are going to be available
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
the the headaches go away
and so one of the things that we're
working on in the future
is extending the support for creating
and managing those virtual environments
from within the ide as well
and so you can look out for that on the
horizon
and then as lou mentioned on the
professional side
if you think those headaches are
challenging as a single data scientist
as a team of python users that can often
present even more of a challenge which
is one of the reasons why we're
investing for those commercial teams
in the package management repository
that supports both r
and python to help make that work
reproducible to help
it folks say what packages should be
allowed
as well as that kind of time travel
capability that i briefly showed
um so that's i think the a long-winded
way of saying well we all
can commiserate with the challenges in
python dependency management
we're going to continue to invest and
make it better but
all of the kind of work we're standing
on the shoulders of giants here
is available to you from within our
studio id
and i just wanted to add to that another
plug for
our our studio zone alex gold who's also
part of the solutions engineering team
is going to be doing a webinar in a
couple of weeks on the challenges of
package management and how to address
them
we're going to be doing a series of blog
posts between now and then
talking about the package management
problem so i encourage you know anyone
who's interested in that
to check it out now sean is there any i
i got a favorite next question but
anything that you want to
jump to before i toss someone out uh so
there was one question i really liked uh
it's a very our studio question which is
to ask
what are the limitations uh and we try
to be pretty upfront with that
um so so i'll just throw out there um
i personally use the rstudio ide when
i'm combining r and python together
i have friends who use the rstudio ide
for all their python work
i have other colleagues who use vs code
for their python work
so kind of our common theme is the tools
should be subservient to you
as a data scientist and not the other
way around so so pick what works for you
but some of the specific limitations
that you might run into that
we're investing to make better but you
you might hit today
are that kind of creation of python
environments i mentioned
you know our studio sits on top of that
but it doesn't really give you tools yet
today for
creating your condor virtual
environments and then the other
limitation i would call out
is that the debugger inside of our
studio
today is still pretty r oriented and so
if you're
spending all day kind of writing a long
python application
and you are using a debugger as a
critical element of that
i would tend to recommend something like
vs code as
maybe a better option so uh lua that's
that's my favorite question talking
about limitations
uh what was your favorite question mine
was a closely related question
which was i can't find it now in the
list but there was something to the
effect of you know
can we now use python within the ide
without
a lot of shenanigans unquote so
um and my view on that is the most
recent release rco 1.4
has lowered the bar of necessary
shenanigans
considerably you want to comment on that
yeah i i would agree as i said i do have
some colleagues
especially those who know r and are
learning python for the first time it
can be really nice to not
introduce yet another editor it can be
challenging when you're trying to learn
a new language to also be learning
a new tool and so i think if you're
someone who knows r
that barrier of entry is low enough now
that you can get started
using python right within the rstudio
ide then if you want to graduate to
another editor
that's fine but at least you're not
learning both those things at once
and i kind of echo that as well to
educators that are out there you know
someone asked
what language should i teach well
i think that the key is to teach what
you're going to be comfortable teaching
to make sure that your students have a
really effective data science experience
from day one
you know that they're not stuck fighting
their tools
uh before they're able to create their
first plot whether that's a matte plot
lib or a gg plot two
you wanna give them that gratifying
moment early on
and it's my belief that a lot of folks
at our studio have done a ton of awesome
work
to ensure that our studio id isn't going
to present that hurdle and isn't going
to fight students
if you are a teacher interested in using
r and python also do a quick shout out
to our studio cloud
which can reduce that hurdle even
further by allowing folks to
to start writing code without installing
anything on day one
and that's a good segue to a question i
wanted to answer
about our studio cloud which is we had a
question is on whether our studio server
is running on premises or in the cloud
or what
our studio server pro typically um
most of our customers will install our
studio server pro themselves but where
they install it varies considerably
it could be on-prem and often is or it
could be
in a virtual private cloud on any of the
major cloud providers
and so our customers do both we also
have marketplace offerings for our
studio server pro
on all three major clouds so you can
search for our studio
in those cloud marketplaces and that's a
quick way of spinning it up
and then of course rstudio.cloud is sean
just mentioned
is a way of getting started with similar
functionality without having to install
anything and that's a hosted service
purchased on a monthly basis there was
also
a question on uh someone asking they
have a license for our studio server pro
is the launcher available or does that
require the enterprise flavor
the the launcher is actually sean let me
i thought i knew the answer that and now
i caught myself could you clarify
yeah i would say you know for those kind
of specific questions
or if you have questions about you know
the professional products
our our sales team is is happy to help
that sounds
like a cheesy ad but i can tell you
firsthand
at our studio our folks that work with
our customers
are all in their own right really
talented data scientists
and they'll be able to help you navigate
some of these questions uh
and you we'd be the first to say you
know you don't need a professional
product the open source stuff will work
or we can help you solve you know some
of the challenges that come up so i
think that's kind of how i would end
things there lou is
we we'd love for you to dive into the
resources dive into that community
thread
and then if you are encountering some of
the challenges that we presented
throughout this webinar
feel free to reach out to us and we are
happy to
help you go through that path as well